[Aplausos]
[Música]
bom geralmente quando eu pergunto para
as pessoas qual é o animal mais perigoso
do mundo
a resposta ela é muitas vezes
influenciada pelos filmes de hollywood
as pessoas falam em grandes animais
elas falam em leões tubarões cobras mas
na verdade o animal mais perigoso do
mundo
cabe na palma da minha mão todos os anos
quase um milhão de pessoas morrem no
mundo por conta da picada de um mosquito
eu não sei quanto a vocês mas para mim
isso é um absurdo em pleno 2017 mais de
um século depois que o homem inventou o
avião quase 50 anos depois que nós
pisamos na lua quase um milhão de
pessoas morrem por conta da simples
picada de um mosquito e que nós temos
feito para impedir isso
e como chegamos nesse número e é isso
que eu vou contar aqui pra vocês
no século 18 uma das grandes moléstias
que acometia humanidade era febre
amarela
milhares e milhares de pessoas morriam
todos os anos inclusive o canal do
panamá que é uma das maravilhas modernas
que temos e levou mais de 35 anos para
ser construído por conta que os
trabalhadores que pra lá iam morriam
pela febre amarela e também pela malária
mas ninguém sabia o que causava a febre
amarela até que em 1981 se lançou pela
primeira vez a hipótese de que o
mosquito está aí transmitindo essa
doença
só que levou aí quase 20 anos para que
fossem então confirmado o mosquito
transmite a febre amarela e com base
nisso começaram várias campanhas para
acabar com o mosquito pois acabando com
o mosquito nós conseguiremos acabar com
a doença
a primeira campanha foi feita em cuba em
1910 da eliminação de criadouros e essa
campanha foi
muito bem sucedida tão bem sucedida que
depois ela foi replicado aqui no brasil
primeiramente no estado de são paulo e
depois no estado do rio de janeiro com
osvaldo cruz osvaldo cruz inclusive
criou as brigadas matamos que que elas
se necessário invadiam a força à casa
das pessoas para eliminar criador
então vamos fazer as contas
já são mais de 115 anos que nós sabemos
que eliminar criadouros é uma ferramenta
eficaz para combater o mosquito ea
situação no brasil ela foi então
momentaneamente controlada
só que mesmo não a gente não pode dizer
o mesmo dos outros países dos países
vizinhos e isso representa um risco pelo
tráfego de pessoas
o edson e jeep é espécie hoje mais
associada ao ser humano onde o ser
humano vai o mosquito vai atrás
eliana de navio de carros de aviano
relevadoras então é em 1913 com essa
preocupação a fundação rockefeller que é
uma instituição norte americana ela
lançou ela criou a comissão
internacional de saúde que tinha como
objetivo atuar na américa latina para
combater a febre amarela e também à
malária em 1918 foi lançada a campanha
mundial de erradicação da febre amarela
através do combate ao mosquito e nesse
caso naquela época com a eliminação dos
criadores em 1926 depois de oito anos de
trabalho foi anunciado que que o litoral
brasileiro né estímulos erradicado já a
febre amarela que era onde estavam é
situados na época os grandes centros
urbanos
esse anúncio é ele é uma faca de dois
gumes porque porque ele levou ao
fechamento de mais 60 postos de combate
ao mosquito e imma em janeiro desculpa
de 1928
as ações de combate ao mosquito controle
vetorial no rio de janeiro ele foi
descontinuado
nós paramos de combater o mosquito
porque em teoria não tinha mais doença
infelizmente quatro meses depois
nós voltamos a ter epidemias
aqui no estado isso nos mostra o que o
controle vetorial independentemente da
ferramenta que você usa ele jamais pode
ser descontinuado controle vetorial é
pra sempre
ele nunca pode parar porque o mosquito e
adin
então os governantes da época aprenderam
com isso e voltaram a fazer controle
vetorial o nosso já até o momento bom e
velho conhecido
em 1942 nós tivemos o último registro da
febre amarela urbana aqui no país
só que mais uma vez nos países vizinhos
a situação não estava controlado o que
representava novamente um risco e no
mesmo ano foi lançada foi falado pela
primeira vez na necessidade de somar
esforços em uma ação conjunta de que
todos os países se unissem de uma
maneira é bastante séria pra conseguir
combater e erradicar o aedes aegypti e
por conta dessa idéia em 1947 foi
lançada a campanha continental para
erradicação do aedes aegypti
baseada principalmente na eliminação de
criadouros e aqui no brasil no mesmo ano
com o uso do ddt
o inseticida muito conhecido nosso e que
infelizmente hoje sabe extremamente
tóxico e cancerígeno
os esforços continuarão e mais ou menos
oito anos depois nós eliminamos o último
foco do aedes aegypti no brasil no
estado da bahia e três anos depois o
brasil foi considerado livre do aedes
aegypti é pra comemorar
só que menos de 10 anos depois ele
voltou ao brasil
ou seja falar hoje em erradicação não é
possível mais
nós podemos falar em controlar a
população do mosquito em suprimir essa
população mas não erradicá lá na década
de 70 o ddt começou a ser banido de todo
mundo mas no brasil não
no brasil ele continuou a ser usado
indiscriminadamente
usava-se toneladas e toneladas de dt
para combater o mosquito
qual o problema disso com o problema do
uso indiscriminado de inseticidas
o inseticida ele não diferencia a
espécie benéfica da espécie nociva
quando você usa inseticida você mata
todos então ele não é espécie específico
não atinge somente o seu alvo aquilo que
você quer combater e no caso do aedes
aegypti aqui no brasil o uso
indiscriminado levou a seleção de
populações resistentes e hoje esse
mosquito é resistente a praticamente
todas as moléculas de inseticidas
disponíveis no mercado
prova de que não funcionava mais
o uso de ddt foi que em 1986 nós tivemos
a nossa primeira epidemia de dengue no
brasil
aqui no estado do rio de janeiro e quase
30 anos depois no resto do mundo com
atraso de quase 30 anos no final da
década de 90 é que nós é paramos de usar
esse inseticida extremamente tóxico
hoje a gente já sabe o que são mais de
100 anos que nós estamos numa guerra
como mosquito porque é isso que nós
vivemos uma guerra
basicamente é de uma maneira muito
simples é uma guerra e pra controlar o
mosquito
usamos as mesmas ferramentas inseticidas
larvicidas eliminação de criadouros por
que essa mr
ao mosquito é a única maneira que nós
temos de controlar as doenças porque
tirando a febre amarela
nós não temos vacina para nenhuma das
doenças que o aedes aegypti transmitir
tem funcionado
será que nosso controle do mosquito para
conseguir controlar a doença tem sido
eficaz
parece que não porque os números das
doenças só crescem em 2016 no ano
passado nós tivemos mais de um milhão e
meio de brasileiros doentes por conta da
dengue
existe um ditado que diz abençoada é a
desgraça que vem só não foi o caso em
2014 nós assistimos de camarote
além da copa das confederações da copa
do mundo a confederações fifa 2013
a chegada do vírus chikungunya por conta
principalmente da copa das confederações
em 2015
o zico chegou em 2016 foi comprovada a
ligação da infecção pelo vírus indica
com um grande espectro de sintomas que
hoje são denominados síndrome congênita
música que nós conhecemos principalmente
o sintoma da microcefalia que teve
números absurdos no nordeste brasileiro
tanto que a organização mundial da saúde
decretou estado de emergência na saúde
pública por conta dos casos da síndrome
congênita da música e esses vírus por
exemplo da chikungunya inclusive eles
estão se espalhando em uma velocidade
muito rápida
pouco tempo depois da entrada deles dois
anos depois em 2016 nós tivemos já 500
mil casos esses 500 mil casos são quase
25 por cento de todos os casos de doença
transmitida pelo aedes aegypti isso
mostra a agressividade desses vírus e
também como eles estão se expandindo se
espalhando no brasil numa velocidade
extremamente rápida e agora nós vamos
fazer para combater esse velho inimigo
nosso
vamos continuar usando as mesmas armas
dando murro em ponta de faca
tem outro ditado que diz que errar é
humano mas persistir no erro é burrice
mas eles não precisam ficar preocupados
existem alternativas eu tenho
alternativas muito boas por sinal uma
delas foi criada na universidade de
oxford em 2002 por pesquisadores que é
chamada tecnologia do gene autolimitante
popularmente conhecido aqui no brasil
como a ex do bem
o que os pesquisadores fizeram eles
injetaram um gene autolimitante no
mosquito que faz com que ele não consiga
se reproduzir da maneira correta faz com
que os seus filhos morreram
é basicamente isso o mosquito foi
hackeado pra agora combater a si próprio
isso é uma quebra é uma mudança de
paradigma porque nós combatemos
mosquitos liberando mais mosquitos e
isso associado somados lembrando daquela
é idéia de 1942 de somar esforços vêm
tendo resultado sem precedentes tanto
aqui no brasil quanto em outros países
então a idéia é liberar mosquito só que
é importante a gente deixar uma coisa
muito claro somente machos são liberados
porque porque macho não [ __ ] ele não se
alimenta de sangue
então ele não transmitir nenhuma doença
e liberar machos é totalmente seguro
para a saúde humana e à saúde dos
animais
uma vez liberado que o macho vai fazer o
que ele faz de melhor
vai procurar a fêmea para cruzar com ela
se eu soltar cinco fêmeas aqui dentro e
até uma lata de inseticida na mão de
cada um de vocês eu duvido que vocês
achem as cinco fêmeas mas sem soltar um
macho som ele vai achar 5 porque ele é
programado para fazer isso faz parte da
biologia dele então o macho é liberado
ele e contra a fêmea cruza com ela essa
fêmea coloca em média
300 ovos ao longo da sua vida
se ela cruzar com o macho geneticamente
modificado é o macho chamado a ex do bem
toda essa prole esses 300 mosquitos vão
morrer antes de chegar à idade adulta
então pra cada cruza que um macho fizer
nós vamos ter na próxima geração até 300
kits a menos e isso sem utilizar nenhum
tipo de químico sem causar nenhum tipo
de desequilíbrio ecológico fazendo isso
ao longo do tempo nós vamos atingir o
que a supressão da população nós vamos
reduzir a população em níveis excelentes
e qual a lei é de vocês reduzir a
população do mosquito que é o grande
benefício da tecnologia qual outra
vantagem dessa tecnologia ela tem um
alvo
ela somente atingir o aedes aegypti
nenhuma outra espécie é impactada por
que nos insetos o cruzamento ele é
espécie específico então a fêmea da
espécie há somente cruza com um macho da
espécie a não das psb nem datas e porque
as genitálias deles se encaixam no
sistema chamado chave e fechadura então
você reduz a população do mosquito e não
causa nenhum tipo de desequilíbrio
ecológico não deixa nenhuma pegada
ecológica e isso já foi feito em
diversos países e continua sendo feito
em diversos biomas diferentes em todos
os projetos realizados
nós atingimos supressões acima de 80%
chegando até 99 por cento de redução na
população do mosquito
lembrando sem causar nenhum
desequilíbrio ecológico
hoje no brasil nós temos projetos em
andamento projetos em larga escala e os
resultados continuam maravilhosos sem
nenhum tipo de desequilíbrio com uma
redução muito grande na população
então essa é uma tecnologia de ponta
conta que vem somar aos esforços que nós
temos feito desde oswaldo cruz porque a
matemática em saúde é um pouquinho
diferente em matemática é na saúde
desculpa você nunca subtrai você sempre
acrescenta
você só soma e numa guerra centenária
que essa que nós vivemos contra o
mosquito quanto mais armas melhor recebe
pelo mosquito
obrigado
[Aplausos]